bonjour à tous émission spéciale ce
mercredi sur france 3 franche comté à
quatre jours du second tour des
élections législatives
nous allons vous proposer en direct
quatre débats entre finalistes de ce
scrutin quatre face à face donc au cours
de l'heure qui vient nous allons aller
dans le territoire de belfort dans le
pays de montbéliard en haute saône
mais d'abord on s'intéresse à la
capitale comtoise besançon avec la
première circonscription du doubs celle
de besançon ouest une partie de la ville
avec les quartiers de battants mon rap
on est plein aux as notamment la
circonscription qui s'étend jusqu'à
saint vite et arc-et-senans et vous
allez voir les résultats de dimanche
dernier la circonscription à pass à
placer largement en tête fanette
charvier de la république en marche avec
un peu moins de 30% des suffrages
elle devance de près de 14 points la
députée socialiste sortante barbara
romagnan les deux finalistes sont sur
notre plateau bonjour mesdames va naître
servier vous êtes arrivé en tête on
commence avec vous vous étiez totalement
inconnus des électeurs il ya un mois
seulement quand vous avez eu
l'investiture en marche elle c'est à
dire que c'est justement exclusivement
cette étiquette en marche qui vous a
permis de réaliser ce score dimanche
dernier alors effectivement l'étiquette
en marche y est pour quelque chose mais
je pense aussi que c'est une mode c'est
une adhésion par conviction auprès de ce
mouvement j'adhère à ses valeurs
j'adhère à sa méthode est justement
depuis mon investiture le 11 mai dernier
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps auprès des
habitants de la circonscription auprès
des acteurs locaux également que j'ai
rencontré et moi c'est une campagne
éclair
c'est une campagne éclair effectivement
mais je j'ai passé beaucoup de temps sur
le terrain pour me faire connaître
justement alors vous n'avez aucune
expérience d'élu même pas simplement
date conseillère municipale on va dire
comment devenir parlementaire sans même
avoir une expérience mêmes fins de
gestion d'une collectivité ou de deux
d'organisation de politiques publiques
mais je sais pas un handicap ça alors
non ce n'est pas un handicap et être
député je rappelle que c'est être député
de la nation et que c'est représenter
ses concitoyens
donc ensuite effectivement il y aura d
apprentissage à faire au niveau de
l'assemblée nationale et son
fonctionnement
je pense que tout le monde peut
apprendre cela moi en tout cas je
m'engage à représenter mes concitoyens
et c'est ça un mandat de député la
nation barbara romagnan vous êtes donc
la députée sortante sur cette
circonscription dimanche vous sembliez
déjà soulagée d'être qualifiés et est
déjà une victoire pour vous d'être au
second tour
non je ne pas le présenter comme ça mais
au regard des résultats nationaux y
compris dans la région jusqu'au temps de
faire de deuxième tour voilà pour mon
recommencer à zéro
vous êtes l'unique socialiste dans ce
cas est-ce que à l'image de christian
paul un autre frondeurs mais en
bourgogne
vous êtes en ballottage défavorable la
fronde est sanctionné à gauche je sais
pas je pense que d'abord ce qui est ce
qui ressort d'abord de ce scrutin et qui
nous rend tout simple c'est le record
d'abstention comme on n'a jamais connu
cinq clairement d'ailleurs dans la
première circonscription les candides
inde en marche qu'on peut féliciter qui
sont arrivés avant je prends juste après
je pense que c'est le souhait que je
partage et que je comprends d'un
renouvellement
on en a marre que ce soit toujours les
mêmes élus qui se représentent et qui se
ressemblent tous mais moi j'attire
l'attention quand même sur le fait qu on
pourrait avoir la verse tous ne sont pas
comme madame charlier qui en effet un
vrai renouvellement il ya aussi beaucoup
de recyclage d'élus plein de qualités
que je connais bien parce qu'ils sont
dans le même parti était dans le même
parti que moi il ya encore quelques
semaines mais j'attire l'attention sur
le fait qu' on critiquer ça parce que du
coup on se dit ça ne représente pas la
société le problème c'est que ce sont
des candidats qui ont tous signé une
charte qui s'engagent à à voter les
projets proposés par le président de la
république moi je comprends ce souci de
cohérence
mais en même temps du coup on va arriver
à des choses ou sur plein de questions
essentielles
on aura pas de débat sur la question du
travail la question de l'école laval est
revenue à madame remaniant
l'événement de l'entre-deux tours on va
dire dans pour votre cas c'est que jean
luc mélenchon vous a apporté nommément
veut son soutien hier à la radio et hier
matin et c'est un privilège mais c'est
un poids pour vous un fardeau non non je
le remercie j'ai une excuse une farce
est une personnalité clivante c'est pour
ça que je vous pose la question
oui c'est vrai mais je pense que dans un
moment où des gens qui viennent de
différents horizons qui finalement on ne
sait pas on né sait pas ce qu'il pense
je pense c'est vraiment un sujet certes
c'est important d'être capable de
discuter avec les autres d'échanger de
progresser de revoir ses points de vue
d'écouter les autres mais c'est
important de dire d'où on parle aussi et
c'est vrai que moi je suis un petit peu
troublé par ce mélange entre un premier
de prime id premier ministre de droite
qui est très à droite des députés
socialistes qui des anciens députés
socialistes qui tout d'un coup se
reconnaissent avec des gens qui
n'avaient rien à voir avec eux je pense
qu'on a aussi besoin de clarté alors de
la clarté fanette charvier barbara
romagnan pointe du doigt cette fameuse
charte d'engagement quel député serez
vous si vous êtes élue dimanche prochain
alors moi effectivement cette charte
gelé signé mais je les signer par
adhésion et par conviction donc c'est
des projets pour auquel j'adhère donc il
me paraît évident d'avoir signé cette
charte qui nous engage et je pense que
c'est important également de savoir où
va un député est de savoir à quoi il
s'engage justement je m'engage à sa
madame romagnan nous dit que à la
république en marshal et surprise de
voir des gens de droite et de gauche
qu'ils se rassembleraient autour d'un
projet commun
et effectivement se rassemblent autour
d'un projet commun je peux vous poser la
même question finalement puisque vous
avez l'étiquette parti socialiste mais
vous soutenez et être soutenus par un
candidat communiste et vous recevez hier
le soutien de jean-luc mélenchon
on se demande un petit peu ce qu'il en
est et est ce que vous allez rester au
parti socialiste où est ce que vous
allez quitter finalement c'est possible
les deux sont possibles c'est à dire que
moi je suis surtout une candidate de
gauche et je pense comme vous même qui
est entré dans un nouveau mouvement que
tout ça est à rediscuter a refondé mais
en même temps comme vous le disiez tout
à l'heure un député il est là pour
représenter ses concitoyens et moi je ne
trouve pas que ce soit tellement claire
l'engagement sur cette charte parce que
vous engager vis-à-vis du président de
la république alors que c'est bien
vis-à-vis des citoyens qu'on doit
s'engager
la question de la loi travail qui devra
qui ne sera pas discutée 1 puisque nous
n'aurons à voter que sur le principe des
ordonnances et à dire qu'on va demander
aux députés
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à vous
dessaisir de votre pouvoir que vous
tenez des citoyens pour que le
gouvernement décide à votre place mais
décide quoi
aujourd'hui on ne le sait pas parce que
le projet on ne le connaît pas vous
l'avez dit vous-même c'est un document
de travail
or les gens votent dimanche et je pense
que ce serait important de savoir je
vous laisse répondre sur les ordonnances
bien sûr alors le projet effectivement
il n'est pas connu pour l'instant
puisque je rappelle quand même qu'on est
en plein travail et que des réunions de
travail vont être organisées jusqu'à la
fin de l'été non ce serait très
prétentieux de dire qu'il est prêt il ne
l'est pas edouard philippe
hier matin encore sur une autre radio a
laissé entendre certaines pistes quand
même on y lit à voix convoque oui ce
sont des devrait aller un peu plus loin
que le
le projet de ce qu'on appelle la loi
elle conneries le document est fait
alors effectivement il ya des pistes de
travail mais le travail je vous le dis
n'est pas encore terminée puisqu'il ya
encore des concertations qui sont amenés
sur les ordonnances je rappelle quand
même que le parlement intervient deux
fois il intervient une première fois sur
la ratification en tout cas sur la loi
d'habilitation qui donne une liberté au
gouvernement sur un sujet précis et pour
une durée donnée de promulguer bien des
ordonnances et une fois que l'ordonnancé
prise et bien le parlement intervient
aussi pour la ratifier elle n'est pas
ratifié leur donnant ce n'est pas prenez
pas voilà ne ne dépasse pas la valeur de
la loi donc le parlement intervient deux
fois mais donc l' ordonnance s'applique
quand même il vous disiez vous même que
le travail sur ce texte se fera jusqu'à
la fin de l'été or le premier ministre a
dit que entre le 24 et le 28 juillet les
parlementaires auront à dire est ce
qu'ils se dessaisisse parce que c'est
bien ça de leur pouvoir au profit du
gouvernement dont moi comme
parlementaire je vois pas comment je
peux dire d'accord je ne connais pas le
projet mais je vous laisse faire et
encore moins les citoyens qui veulent
qu'ils vont voter dans quatre jours je
vais pas je vais pas dire quelque chose
de plus voilà les ordonnances il ya deux
interventions du parlement la première
donnée une loi d'habilitation et la
deuxième ratifié ce qui aura été
présenté mais vous en tant que député si
vous êtes élu vous êtes favorable à plus
de souplesse pour le code de travail
plus de liberté pour les chefs
d'entreprise et moi je suis favorable à
l'ensemble de ce projet et ce serait un
petit peu réducteur de limiter ça
a effectivement
les instances prud'homales par exemple
la loi travail elle est là pourquoi elle
est là parce que il faut prendre en
considération et agir vite pour lutter
contre le chômage
donc si effectivement le bilan du
gouvernement précédent avait été un
petit peu plus efficace sur ce thème
on n'aurait pas besoin d'aller vite
aujourd'hui c'est vrai mais c'est quand
même monsieur mâcon qui était ministre
de l'économie
oui enfin le gouvernement s'était quand
même celui de monsieur hollande
absolument contre lequel j'ai vu
aujourd'hui gel aujourd'hui il est
impératif d'aller vite sur la question
du chômage je pense pas que nos
concitoyens aient encore du temps à
perdre et je pense pas qu'ils aient
encore envie qu'on sacrifie des gens sur
l'autel du chômage de masse il faut
aller vite sur ces questions-là barbara
romagnan pointillés une question de
forme avec les ordonnances et le rôle
des parlementaires mais cela vous oppose
aussi sur le fond oui bien sûr sur la
question du plafonnement des indemnités
prud'homale ça veut dire qu'on va
plafonner les indemnités pour des
licenciements illégaux ont dit des
licenciements sans cause réelle et
sérieuse donc moi je pense que quand les
gens sont licenciés pour des raisons
illégal on ne peut pas plafonnés c'est
ses indemnités de même que ça doit être
à la hauteur du préjudice qu'ils aient
subi de même que privilégier les accords
d'entreprise sur les accords de branche
je pense que c'est vraiment un problème
pour les salariés et pas du tout un
avantage pour l'emploi aujourd'hui il ya
plein de négociations au niveau de
l'entreprise et c'est très bien et c'est
souhaitable je pense que c'est important
pour le dynamisme du du marché du
travail
mais aujourd'hui ce qui est proposé
c'est que l'accord d'entreprise puisse
être supérieure à l'accord de branche or
l'accord de branche c'est ce qui permet
que des salariés qui sont dans des
entreprises des mêmes des toutes petites
entreprises où il n'y a pas de
représentation des salariés puissent
bénéficier de ses droits donc je pense
que c'est un vrai danger et je ne vois
pas en quoi c'est susceptible de créer
de l'emploi mais alors justement fenêtre
chargé dit c'est la solution pour créer
de l'emploi et enfin en finir avec le
chômage de masse vous quelles solutions
alternatives vous proposez moi je pense
que aujourd'hui on constate que le
travail est déjà partagée entre les gens
qui ont un emploi parfois trop et qui on
souffre même quand ils aiment leur
travail et 6 millions de gens qui sont
inscrits à pôle emploi et au milieu
plein de gens surtout des femmes des
plus jeunes des précaires qui ont soit
un travail à temps partiel
82% des travailleurs à temps partiel
sont des femmes et plus de la moitié
vivent avec moins de 800 euros par mois
et tous ceux qui sont toujours obligés
de passer
un d'emplois en intérim ou en cdd
souvent des cdd qui sont inférieurs à un
mois donc moi je dis pas que c'est
facile mais c'est pas en permettant de
licencier plus facilement le rendant
moins coûteux qu'on crée davantage
d'emplois
je vous laisse répondre oui simplement
il n'y a pas que la loi travail qui va
permettre de devenir lutter contre le
chômage
il y a aussi d'autres lois puis ça
s'inscrit dans un projet beaucoup plus
globale des lois qui vont permettre de
redonner du pouvoir d'achat via la
réforme des cotisations sociales des
lois qui vont venir améliorer la
formation professionnelle par le biais
d'un plan d'investissement important des
lois qui vont permettre également
d'étendre l'assurance chômage pour tous
donc ça je crois que c'est vraiment très
important et c'est un projet global
qu'il faut voir c'est pas juste le zoom
sur sur la loi travail il nous reste un
peu plus de 3 minutes 30 avant votre
conclusion est ce que vous vous donne
carte blanche est ce que voulait
interpeller votre adversaire sur une
thématique précise
vous parlez d'une thématique précise de
votre propre chef barbara romagnan je
vous laisse comment ces voiliers faut
pour moi la priorité ce sera la question
écologique parce que c'est une question
de vie ou de mort pour nous tous pour
les animaux et tous les êtres vivants
cdu c'est une question éminemment social
parce que tout ceux qui le subissent qui
ne sut qui subissent le fait que la
transition écologique ne soit pas fait
ce sont d'abord les plus pauvres qui
habitent dans des logements qui sont à
mille îles isolées que ce soit en
secteur urbain ouvrons secteur rural
c'est pour ça que je voterai contre tout
ce qui permettra de favoriser des
énergies polluantes mais tout ce que
près semblablement proposera nicolas
hulot pour aller dans ce sens là et en
matière de justice je suis favorable aux
propositions qu'a fait monsieur berrou
mais je suis un peu troublé par son
comportement à lui présentement qui est
un petit peu en contradiction avec ce
qu'il défend fletcher j'ai carte blanche
pour wii donc moi effectivement en
dehors du contrat avec la nation auquel
j'adhère j'ai également des projets que
je souhaite porter parce qu'il me
tiennent à coeur
ça va être le cas par exemple de la
simplification administrative parce
qu'aujourd'hui moi je la vis et je la
vois tous les jour de par mon travail
cette complexité administrative qui nuit
à nos concitoyens et qui entraîne
beaucoup de ruptures et
d'incompréhension donc il faut enfin que
ça cesse je souhaite également porter
engagé en tout cas une réflexion sur le
handicap en france aujourd'hui sur la
place des familles et de leurs aidants
parce qu'aujourd'hui je pense que notre
société elle doit être capable d'inclure
les enfants porteurs de handicap à
l'école quand c'est possible d'inclure
les adultes porteurs d'un handicap dans
un travail lorsque cela est possible et
qu'on puisse également leur garantir
l'accès à des soins adaptés et
pertinents et l'accès à des équipements
spécialisés au prix juste
barbara romagnan votre conclusion que
nous accordent 45 secondes pour vous
adresser aux électeurs de cette 1ère
circonscription qu'est ce que vous
voulez leur dire pour les convaincre de
voter pour vous dimanche prochain il y
aura de toute façon dimanche une
majorité écrasante en faveur du
président de la république de surcroît
ces candidats ont signé une charte dans
laquelle ils s'engagent à voter comme il
leur a dit d'ailleurs c'est normal ils
sont élus grâce à leur association au
président de la république
moi je vous dis à nouveau chères
concitoyennes et chers concitoyens que
l'assemblée nationale vous appartient
que les députés sont là pour représenter
le peuple et non pas le président de la
république et que moi en votre nom je
vous ai dit pourquoi je voterais une
vraie transition écologique contre quoi
je voterai cette réforme de la loi
travail cette augmentation de la csg
notamment pas là de charger votre
conclusion
alors pour conclure moi je dirais que la
république en marche c'est un mouvement
qui est né qui s'est construit qui vit
et qui vivra par le débat démocratique
et pour le débat démocratique
avoir une forte majorité présidentielle
n'empêchera pas le débat donc je
remercie bien évidemment tout tous ceux
et toutes celles qui se sont déplacés
aux urnes dimanche dernier et qui ont
appelé de leur vote
un renouvellement de la vie politique et
j'appelle tous les progressistes qui ne
souhaitent pas voir le pays bloquées par
la gauche de la gauche pour les cinq
prochaines années voter pour des
candidats progressistes et votez pour
moi merci beaucoup à tout les deux je
vous souhaite une bonne fin de campagne
tout de suite un nouveau débat
[Musique]
le temps que nos deux nouveaux invités
s'installent je vous présente leur
circonscription il s'agit de la deuxième
du territoire de belfort
c'est le nord du département en fait et
vous allez voir les résultats cette
circonscription a placé en tête le
candidat de la république en marche
bruno kern avec quasiment 30% des
suffrages le député udi sortant michel
zumkeller est à 23 et mis un peu plus de
six points derrière donc nos deux
finalistes sont en plateau bonsoir à
vous deux bruno kern il s'agit pour vous
d'un retour en politique retour gagnant
en tout cas dimanche dernier pour le
premier tour vous lancez un socialiste
l'ancien premier adjoint à la mairie de
belfort quasiment un tiers des électeurs
a choisi le bulletin à votre nom vous
considérez avoir bénéficié à plein de la
vague mâcon d'abord je remercie les
électeurs de la circonscription de
l'avoir fait deuxièmement j'ai une de
lire une surprise dans la mesure où et
en face un député sortant
celui ci a naturellement